deux en division 2 sont dans ce nouveau
décor effectivement on a changé
d'endroit incroyable talent ça vous
plaît autant qu'avant tout cas
aujourd'hui on va jouer à the doll c'est
à fabien d'afrique du lac avec des
poupées ces [ __ ] de poupée que foot
ou slip et on se bat pour quoi au 11
cherchent de l'aide
un gardien de nuit 30 $ l'heure ça sent
l'arnaqué aux abattements thierry cassât
mardi en gros pour l'histoire c'est une
usine qui a fermé parce que les enfants
voulaient des poupées vous savez un peu
plus électroniques dans lesquels on peut
donner le biberon tout ça et ça c'est
des vieux jouets des vieilles poupées et
vous savez maintenant sur foot ces
poupées et avec a racheté une usine qui
a relancé la fabrication froid et nous
voilà on doit surveiller la la nuit quoi
hattori 6 exact il ya eu le téléphone
qui sonne aux lumières s'éteignent ci
dessus on a les caméras on a les caméras
avec make à six en vue caméra mon gars
mais c'est scandaleux on est là elle est
là cette petite poupée de merde hockey
dans ce couloir là ok là y'a rien là il
y en a là aussi elle se rapproche mais
qu elle se rapproche mais sur six cent
mille quoi j'ai cru que c'est une petite
usine de familiale rd oui il traîne une
hache le bébé il n'est pas là il est pas
là il est pas la merde merde ça doit
être là ça doit être là c'est sûr [ __ ]
nickel je sais pas qui les a attirés
mais c'est un vrai plusieurs vies ok on
est passé deuxième nuit firth shift bon
après la nuit c'est le tuto va pas se
mentir
quoi quoi quoi
quoi quoi c'est quoi ce jeu bruit mais
qu aucun char l'épreuve en bas les
couilles cherche pas à comprendre au
caire il juste à côté donc j'ai bien
fait de fermer celle de droite là y'a
rien là y'a rien on est tranquille et ce
qui est toujours à droite d'autres oui
il est laïque ans donc j'ai sa porte
fermée bombe a les couilles adresse qui
est toujours là ok il est reparti il est
reparti en arrière on est bien à tort
fawcett morte avec ce qu'on fait tout
est restée au mois la fois que madoff
s'est superbement la deuxième nuit il
est quelle heure il va être trois heures
dans pas longtemps on comprend avec
cette horloge mais qui sait lire l'heure
là dessus à gauche y'a rien hier est
allé km sont partis faire un road trip
allait se plaît c'est fini il est 5h
déconne pas au [ __ ] mais bon là on est
bon là c'est fini c'est fini mais qu
troisième nuit
deuxième round 5 heures encore [ __ ]
j'y perds moment que les prix en cdi un
poste pour les risques qu'on prend
l'avantagé sur cette bonne chose près je
me donne chaud qu'on fera sur un
camarade carrière en baisse à ça
consomme d'électricité en sorte pour
elle est restée c'est le boss qui paye
c'est pas nous je m'en bats les couilles
puisqu'on a amputé juste à côté juste à
côté cet acte et il va venir et sera
menée va sera menée que c'est bon il est
pas là l'autre côté il ya rien il comme
toujours vous pensez il pillay plat il
n'est pas non plus mais où il est passé
toujours rien on est pas mal hélas
combien de rs 3 2 heures et demie et
deux heures et demie
il est terrifié avec jet parce qu'il est
arrivé à cette petite poupée choix qui a
fait quoi avec mais c'est terrible ça
pleure ça y est t'es toi tais toi tais
toi y'a pas ta maman qu'est la torah pas
de biberon va crever c'est pas toi qui
pleure quand même defla bien oui il ya
un bruit il nous reste combien une heure
à l'est une heure du caire franchement
tu veux le faire il me reste tellement
de power c'est quoi on peut terminer les
deux portes fermées et là on est
vraiment me vallet vous allez boire un
café
je vous jure je faire
au café le café questor ça je suis
arrivé en courant tellement vite que ça
fait un vent de ouf et le mur s'est
décrochée m'est tombé dessus et regarder
un peu comme une épée en plus ce mur pas
du tout à part voir à moitié cassé alors
du coup là on n'a pas suivi où sont les
poupées ce qui fait que on va être en
difficulté en plus plus on avance plus
c'est difficile c'est bien mathieu bombe
à 7 sur 10 matthieu 7 sur 10 bat le café
au québec la plus haute avec nous c'est
reparti je sais que sur bagdad après 10
vers les nuits les plus difficiles au
fait c'est juste à temps d'allumer la
lumière temps en temps pour voir s'il ya
quelque chose et les caméras
non sans mal compris ce couplage en plus
d'infos comment gâcher un max de courant
là là on est bien on est tellement bien
qu'on peut se permettre une petite pause
café à la vôtre il arrivait tout y'a
rien à gauche ni à droite ni mélenchon
ni sarkozy excellent va regarder sial
s'ils sont à droite
ouais ouais il y en un qui est juste
dans le couloir la mecque c'est chaud je
pense qu'on est pas mal mais clar
l'heure n'est pas mal là on est pas mal
ok de l'autre côté ça arrivait j'ai
entendu sa salle une tête de bébé là ok
c'est reparti un max de plaisir de faire
ça en boucle
y'a pas de bébé au fond pas des voeux en
vue à droite on est bien à droite on est
très très bien on n'est pas du tout la
beac est long il est rentré e mail c'est
exceptionnel on va la passer cette nuit
mexes pas possible voilà pacéré avait
comme on est concentrés là on peut que
la passerelle 1 quand tu puisses les
yeux tu sais que tu te regarde comme un
gros porc à gauchy rien là il ya un bébé
qui est donc loire la maille fait pas
trop tarder à arriver au cul on n'est
pas maladroite il ya un bébé aussi qu'il
va pas tarder à arriver [ __ ] merde
doit fermer à droite et on va attendre
solides gauches patiemment lâché en
train de faire un plan monga stade
jacques diouf à gauche et à quoi il est
plus là il est plus là il est pas là non
plus peut-être que là en fait ils
passent dans le conduit mais oui [ __ ]
quelle découverte à trois tournées où
y'a rien y'a rien soit l'aider à la
porte soit il est pas là on est bien il
reste combien de temps il reste une
heure et demie deux heures ok ça peut le
faire
ça peut pas le faire halléguen falloir
économiser mais un truc de ouf comme
cote à cette heure que tu achetais tout
premier jeu sur console
comment il est passé
comment il est passé et ses
chorégraphies claquer leur garder le bon
mec là strike on va tous les français
qui ont fait direct un état des lieux
sur la gauche on n'a rien on n'a rien on
a cela dit c'est un très beau et fluide
cet appartement non memex totalisé
bourreau qui est dernier au court terme
gloucester
c'est parti à droite on en est où il est
juste là toujours il bouge pas c'est
très bien pour nous
et la pire idée ça va le faire personne
à droite c'est correct à gauche péter
dans laquelle sombre
elles sont non plus on est bien on est
allé lite on économise ses shows
ignorait 55% de courant pour deux heures
et demie mais non je peux pas faut taire
six heures passées un choeur sac non mon
plan tombe à l'eau mec
ok nous reste actuellement deux heures
deux heures soit jusqu'à 6 heures je
parle pour me rassurer
oui on a ou à droite il y en a ok ça
m'arrivait de la droite à gauche du coup
je pense pas qu'il en ait un non on est
bien il note qu une heure on a 10%
ça va être très compliqué il est
toujours là je pense qu'à gauche c'est
arrivé donc je vais faire mais je vais
attendre et là c'est là qu'il faut prier
c'est là qu'il faut prier mais qui
passera pas ce mec je sais que j'ai de
réouvrir ça passe ça passe on y est il
est toujours là et toujours là s'est
amusé commencé dur aussi bien [ __ ] je
trouve fort je fais tomber les murs
voilà j'en tire toi de ses vidéos sur
the doors je suis totalement regarder à
une argue encore là en ouvrant sa bouche
ah tiens tout de suite je vais te mettre
les deux doigts dans la gorge et eu à
vomir des triplettes de belleville
ça vous a vu ma mine de rien c'est pas
mal et c'est bien là dessus que t elle
crèche à noël fait à peu près ça ça a
craqué je passion d'entendre s'amuse
vraiment c'était pas mal on aurait quand
même aimé plus d'animations quand il ya
du summer la sfio le bébé qui assure à
la tenue prochaine d'une omerta me
regarde et portez vous bien thiandoum